mon mon pote tar là ça y est tout le
monde là il y a le nouveau variant qui
est en train de monter en puissance il
est en train de tous nous mettre en
Racer tous ceux qui l'attrapent sont
dans le mal sachez-le en plus il a des
nouveaux symptômes je par des nouveaux
symptômes c'est un truc de ouf il y a
des trucs sur les doigts sur les doigts
de pied en dessous des y bon vous allez
voir on a Robert qui va nous voir dans
un instant infectiologue à la pitié sal
pétrière qui viendra nous en parler
regardez regardez le nouveau variant il
arrive il monte en puissance ce
Tarb
allons-nous repartir 3 ans en arrière et
revivre la même situation
cauchemardesque de 2020 nous sommes en
guerre l'ennemi est là invisible
insaisissable qui progresse c'est en
tout cas ce que commence presque à
craindre certains spécialistes
aujourd'hui en cause l'apparition d'un
nouveau variant qui se propage à vitesse
grand V et qui semble aboner avec lui de
nouveaux symptômes dont la perte de
Louis et des jambes qui pourraient
devenir bleu chez certaines personnes
contaminées il faut avoir des réflexes
encore une fois le masque c'est banal
quand on a des symptômes une situation
qui pourrait s'empirer avec la baisse
des températures conséquence la campagne
de vaccination pour les plus fragiles a
été avancée pour faire face à la
situation oui dès le 2 octobre avec de
semaines d'avance sur le calendrier
initialement prévu alors la montée en
puissance de nouveaux variants et le
nombre de personnes infectées commence à
inquiéter doit-on avoir
peur merci Robert quel bonheur de vous
revoir en plus SZ tellement bon vous
avez m' pass parf préér mes parfums
préférés que vous portez infectiologue à
la pitié salpérière on va parler euh de
covid est de retour ça y est là il na
jamais arrêté il a toujours circulé avec
des taux extrêmement faibles en
particulier l'été mais enfin des
spécialistes on a vu des gens avec des
formes peu sévères à partir du moment où
vous avez un virus qui circule il peut
muter et là effectivement avec le climat
les gens ne se ne se protègent pas mais
moi je veux pas être catastrophique si
vous voulez c'est vrai qu'il y a une
montée en puissance ouais alors on est
comme on teste beaucoup moins on n' pas
les mêmes résultats qu'on avait avant
c'està-dire àd que là vous savez que
l'alerte à l'époque c'était 50 cas pour
100000 habitants là on est autour de 20
pour 100000 habitants mais comme on
teste très très peu alors ce qui arrive
c'est qu'on a il y a des petits cousins
de ce fameux au micron si vous voulez on
en a deux là il y a Eris et pyola Pirola
Pirola le deuxè il s'appelle Pirola
c'est c'est le il est pas pire mais
c'est le BA
2.86 alors c'est pas qu'il nous inquiète
il devient un petit peu dominant
c'està-dire vous savez on est
le nouveau venu écrase celui le
précédent alors il est plus contagieux
effectivement c'est qu'on a plus de cas
il est pas très très grave ce qu'on voit
à l'hôpital on a pas non non mais je
veux vraiment calmer on a des symptômes
ORL des formes quelques formes
digestives qu'on des nouveau trucs qui
il y a des jambes qui deviennent bleu
qui sont lourd et qui picotent non
écoutez moi j'ai pas vu ça j'ai vu j'ai
vu des
problèmes non non vous vous avez vous
avez
ce covid a on a tout vu on a tout vu
mais ce qu'on voit en plus aujourd'hui
c'est plus la sphère ORL de la fièvre de
la fatigue quelques troubles quelques
troubles digestif de concentration la
perte de loui on dit pas perte de Louis
oui d'accord non alors vous saz qu'au
début on avait la perte de l'odorat et
la perte du goût maintenant il y a là
moi j'ai pas eu je peux pas je veux pas
généraliser j'en ai pas vu si vous
voulez la seule chose si vous voulez
c'est que on a une certaine immunité
collective il n'est pas très dangereux à
ce jour si vous voulez pour une majorité
de la population le problème reste
toujours problème des comorbidités et
des personnes âgées ça ça reste
malheureusement toujours toujours
d'actualité raison pour laquelle je vais
pe faire taper dessus le vaccin ben le
vaccin il va revenir vent il va revenir
on a avancé la campagne de vaccination
c'est ça c'est un vaccin qui est il y a
un vaccin bivalent il est efficace il y
a un
vaccin
pres il est il est il agit il agit
normalement il est il est efficace sur
ce nouveau variant bien que le pyrola on
a trouvé 40 mutations sur la protéine
Spike et vous savez que c'est la vous
savez le petit spicule qu'on voit sur le
virus et c'est cette protéine si vous
voulez avec laquelle on fait un vaccin
donc aujourd'hui on n'est pas on n'est
pas sur du confinement des passes
sanitaires des passes vaccinaux en plus
c'est pas audible pardon de vous dire ça
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui parler de la
covid les gens il y a une sorte de
sidération ils ont ils veulent plus en
entendre parler ça c'est sauf que le bon
sens c'est je vois plus en plus de gens
qui l'ont moi oui mais tout à fait mais
non mais moi je vous confirme il y a une
comme on teste moins on n pas on n pas
une photographie de la réalité si vous
voulez mais le bon sens fait que si le
covid tu sors c'est chaud là j'ai
entendu quelqu'un là qui a éternué un
truc de fou que si on est positif le bon
sens fait qu'on doit porter un masque en
particulier dans des milieux fermés dans
les transports en commun et O ça c'est
une responsabilité que les gens doivent
avoir il y a pas d'obligation il faut
être il faut être malgré tout prudent et
comme on va avoir en même temps si vous
voulez ce virus il va devenir habituel
il va devenir saisonnier comme on avait
dans le passé quatre coronavirus
c'està-dire queon aura la grippe et on
aura le covid une fois par an en automne
c'est pour ça que on est en train de
faire des recommandations sur un vaccin
à la fois covid et gripe moi je
préconise ne pas les faire en même temps
parce que s'il arrive quoi que ce soit
on saura au moins le des de donc
j'attends 8 jours si vous voulez en
général entre la vaccination contre la
grippe et contre la covid il faut savoir
que l'immunité elle diminue avec le
temps particulier chez les personnes
âgées et ma recommandation de médecin si
vous voulez c'est qu'à partir de 65 ans
autour 65 ans on doit faire un rappel à
l'automne et ça devrait suffire alors
juste on dit qu'il y a maintenant des
jambes qui deviennent bleues je que
c'est vrai éruption cutanée ou des
tombous la perte de Louis ok persistant
pendant plusieurs jours il y a eu ça
c'est vrai et et il y a difficulté
d'élocution et de concentration
jean-michelêes vous avez un covid
persistant non mais c'est non mais vous
av un covid long et et et toujours les
mêmes symptômes la per de l'OD a cyil le
le le côté élocution et concentration
nous laavan c'est ce qu'on appelle les
covid long on a des gens qui viennent et
qui disent qu'effectivement depuis
qu'ils ont attrapé le covid ils ont
intellectuellement ils se sentent un
petit peu un petit peu moins moins
performant que ce qu'ils étaient avant
c'est toujours difficile de trouver la
causalité avec le virus et les troubles
qu'on trouve ici Mund on sait que tu as
eu un covid très compliqué est-ce que ça
te fait peur le retour du covid alors
moi ça me parle bien évidemment parce
que je l'ai subi plein de fouets euh je
suis content de vous voir aussi docteur
parce que vous êtes immunisé c'est bien
oui je suis déjà immunisé puis je l'ai
pas rechopé depuis mais le souci qu' a
eu c'est que moi j'ai ma fille alors la
veille de faire la première le 4
septembre j'ai ma fille moi qui a eu un
un covid asymptomatique d'accord et qui
ça lui a déclenché une arthrite
immunoréactive c'est-à-dire que du
liquide c'est logé sur ses hanches ce
qu'on appelle un rhume de hanche elle ne
pouvait plus marcher donc on a dû aller
justement à à aux urgences et du fait
que du fait que justement bah on pouvait
rien faire il fallait juste attendre il
fallait plus qu'elle fasse de sport
pendant 15 jour elle va super bien j'
l'embrasse très fort elle va beaucoup
mieux mais c'était assez assez in c'est
réversible he révible comme un bouson
quoi non mais ça et
donc V c'est vrai quoi donc il faut
aller se faire vacciner pour vous encore
les enfants je je répète que la
recommandation elle est en particulier
chez les personnes après 65 ans parce
qu'on sait qu'avec l'âge si vous voulez
il y a une le système immunitaire est
moins performant et qu'il y a une baisse
de l'immunité qui se fait au bout de 6
mois donc la recommandation elle est là
bien entendu on regarde et on va de plus
en plus tester donc on saura quelle est
la réalité on va faire ce qu'on appelle
des séquençages pour savoir exactement
est-ce que c'est le pyola qui est
dominant ou est-ce que les ris c'est
toujours là puisque céit le précédent
est-ce qu'il y en a un nouveau et ça
c'est extrêmement important et de tester
à chaque fois être sûr que les vaccins
qui sont disponibles sont efficaces mais
je rappelle Cyr queil y a un traitement
aujourd'hui et que chez les personnes
âgées il y a un médicament qui s'appelle
le Pax lovide le Pax lovide oui c'est un
traitement il existe depuis quelques
mois Pax lov P x lovide L V voilà ce
sont des
comprimés tu
viens j'ess j'essaie d'être sérieux j'
séux Pol qui
pass le le Pax lovide est un médicament
efficace qu'on prescrit pendant 5 5 à 6
jours à deux comprimés par jour et il
est extrêmement efficace chez les
personnes dès qu'ils ont contracté un
covid en particulier à partir d'un
certain âge c'est
important
une oui oui oui il est tout à fait
valide et disponible dans notre pays
merci Robert Seb infectiologue et la
pitié sal c'est toujours un bonheur de
vous avoir merci d'avoir été là vous la
vraie info paxov je connaissis pas
quelqu'un connaiss ici ça m'étonne pas à
tout de
suite